[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation those of us who are
writers have a peculiar relationship to
Stephen Johnson basically we think that
it's not fair that a he doesn't keep
writing the same book like most of us do
he does a completely new subject every
year or so and that he can do that and
master the subject that he takes on as
he did with emergence for example as he
did with everything bad is good for you
and as he has done with the new book
called the ghost map which he'll talk
about a little bit tonight in a much
larger context he is a a polymath and he
can do it in writing
he can do it in presenting as you'll see
and will he please welcome Stephen
Johnson thank you very much Stewart
that's far too kind I think I'll just
leave it at that
I don't want to disappoint anyone after
that introduction I want to thank a few
people first those of you who preferred
the 7:30 time who nonetheless made it
here today I'm particularly grateful to
you clearly the strategy going forward
should be to vary the time slightly with
each event just to throw people off and
see who you're really loyal customers
are and I want to thank long now which
I'm a huge fan of and and folks like
Stewart and Kevin and Danny and Esther
and Bryan and Alexander whose work I've
just been admiring up close and from
afar for a long time it's a great
institution this event which I've never
seen any of these talks but I've kind of
followed them online since they came
around and so it's an honor to be here
as part of this I'm going to talk about
this idea the the long zoom technically
you're required to come up with the
catch phrase that has the long something
there's the long boom and the long tail
and the long now the long zoom and boom
I think is very exciting that it rhymes
like that so it's just an extension of
the whole brand that I'm very proud of
but it is it some of these themes are
going to be kind of worked into my next
book which which right now is not
actually called the long zoom but who
knows what's gonna happen it's still a
long way off but in some ways I'm gonna
be looking at some of the themes that
have shown up in the in the last couple
of books and kind of explain them in the
context of what I mean by the long zoom
it's it's especially nice to be asked to
come here at long now to talk about this
idea because this is is really not an
idea about kind of thinking across the
the scales of time but rather thinking
more across different spatial scales and
across different disciplines it's the
the conceptual move from the from the
very large to the very small and being
able to kind of capture all the scales
in between those stages and to use that
framework in a useful way that's that's
what I'm calling the long zoom and I I
wanted to just start like one
acknowledging that this is not a new
idea what I think is interesting here is
that it's it's a framework or it's a
perspective that's becoming increasingly
kind of current and contemporary and
accessible thanks to technology and
science and in some ways to popular
culture which I'll talk about a little
bit but I thought it'd be useful just to
start with a little bit of prior art to
acknowledge some of the some of the
things that had happened in in the past
some icons of this kind of perspective
the the first is this classic sequence
from porch of the artists the young man
where the young Stephen Dedalus kind of
writes in his notebook
during his class his his kind of place
in the world Stephen Dedalus class of
elements the college valence County
Kildare Ireland Europe the world the
universe that's the kind of where I am
where am I in the world long zoom
perspective how do I fit in and all
these things but probably more recent
kind of iconic visual representation of
this of course is powers of 10 I'll just
show you a snippet of this is now one
about 40 years old 30 years old and
what's so so great about this I think
looking at this now is is how exotic
this view was and how now it just pretty
much looks like Google Earth right I
mean this is elaborate cutter
contraption to show to think about
thinking across scales and how you could
zoom all the way out and and now we
literally are like oh I need to do that
to figure out the traffic directions to
this place the baseball game we're going
to today and so it's literally this this
kind of perspective on the world is it's
at our fingertips in a way that we could
only really dream about and I and I also
like the way that in this part of it you
you kind of zoom out to that vision of
the whole earth that had you know seemed
so empowering to to Stuart so many years
ago
and it was so empowering to so many
people and I think in some ways what
we're talking about here is is not just
what happens when you can see the whole
earth and in kind of one frame but what
happens when you can then move from that
frame all the way into the guy's hand in
the and the picnic blanket and then all
the way into the you know some atomic
particles revolving around inside that
hand that's the that's the long zoom
perspective and then just update it I
could have shown you a million examples
of this but the one I thought was kind
of the the catchiest is I'm just showing
you a part of this this is the opening
sequence of Fight Club
there you go I'm not and it's no sound
here but you get the idea it actually
starts inside all the way inside you
know kind of synaptic firings inside
Edward Norton's brain and then slowly
kind of zooms out all the way to the
little beads of sweat and then all the
way back to the to the gun barrel of the
gun
and then to the actual kind of opening
shot
now you see him there
but you know every other episode of CSI
has the sequence like that now - you
know this is this is a cover place and
part of this is when you start seeing
these instance ways of seeing showing up
in in the popular culture as just as
kind of device that people use again and
again the the part of you goes okay
there's something happening here there's
a certain kind of perspective or
framework in this case it's a it's a
moving across perspectives but that's
where you start thinking there's
something something interesting and
resident is happening and then the other
little piece of prior art I wanted to
show you where the the graphics of this
or even better than the David Fincher is
this sketch that I thought Stewart had
done but it turns out Alexander Rose had
done but this in the clock know long now
book and I love I just think this is a
great sketch and this is really about
time this is what happens if you look
across these different scales the point
is that on these different scales they
kind of move at fundamentally different
speeds fashion is just fantastic up
there that is exactly the shape of
fashion in some ways I think the one
thing that I not I would correct but I
think we were so I'm going to talk a lot
about using the long zoom perspective on
culture and I think in this case culture
is is talking about kind of long-term
cultural changes and I would actually
the kind of culture I'm talking about
closer say to pop culture is probably
sitting there somewhere between fashion
and commerce moving at a much faster
rate there's an interesting question
whether that deeper culture is also
accelerating as well or whether it's
that kind of culture continues to exist
at that slower pace that's something I
don't fully have the answer to so what
I'm going to try and talk about in a
sense is is freezing this not looking at
that kind of forward projection in time
but kind of taking of one big vertical
slab up through the middle and looking
at at a couple of case studies where
I've tried to analyze something across
all these different scales and and
hopefully make the case that this is a
useful way of seeing the world and and
talk a little bit about what happens
when you see the world that way I wanted
to to start with the story that's at the
center
of my new book the ghost map the last
book I wrote before the ghost map was a
book about basically video games and
television shows so I went on to the
next logical thing which is 19th century
cholera and and actually you know one of
the funny things when you do this so
we'd serve it's kind of alluding to it
in the in his wonderful introduction
when you jump around from topic to topic
like that reviewers really like to make
connections and they like to show the
continuity and explain what it is that
connects these two books and and I kept
saying to people there are actually
different books there's I just decided
to write about something different there
isn't really a common theme and all
these reviews of the ghost map would try
and kind of figure out ways to relate it
back to this book about video games and
so there were all these kind of comic
attempts where people would be they
would say well with cholera Johnson
finally has to admit that some things
are actually bad for you you know did
other hood was like you know in in in
the figure of Jon Snow the doctor
railing against the medical orthodoxy of
the day Johnson clearly sees an ally and
his battle against the video game haters
out there no I doubt it all what do you
died was so anyway but but one of the
things that happened was I wrote this
this piece about the the game Spore
which I meant talked about at the end
which visitors to this event have heard
much about in the past and it was a
piece about this idea of the long zoom
and and I realized as I was writing the
piece that that was the common thread
that United these two projects that they
both were kind of anchored around this
long zoom perspective and so it turned
out there was kind of a secret link
between these two books but
interestingly I hadn't been aware of it
until I actually had finished both of
them so that's that's what happens when
you write books they have a life of
their own so the ghost map is set in
it's a true story set in 1854 in London
and the in late August and early
September of 1854 and it's an enormous
Lee interesting period in terms of the
history of cities because London at that
point was the the largest city the in
both in the world and the largest city
of the world had ever seen it was two
and a half million people by comparison
Paris was about you know
1.2 or 1.3 million at this at this time
and it was effectively a a modern kind
of industrial Victorian city living with
an Elizabethan you know kind of public
health infrastructure it had no real
waste management it had no real public
health system and people were literally
kind of drowning in their own filth I
was saying to Stewart before that I've
talked about this book a little bit at
talks where they were basically kind of
breakfast events and it turns out that
people don't really want to hear about
intestinal diseases while they're having
breakfast it's a it's an odd thing I had
not anticipated yeah but you had this
situation where literally the you know
the city people would have these
cesspools with with human waste in their
basement kind of three feet deep and you
had an enormous amount of livestock just
kind of running through the city people
had cows and their attics that they
would keep their from milk and not just
the horses but there were
slaughterhouses in the middle of the
city and it had to kind of crucial
effects that are that are central to
this story the first is it was an
enormous ly smelly city it was an you
know any any description of London from
the period whether you read Dickens or
Mayhew or angles you know kind of starts
and then with which with this sense of
you walk in and you're just overwhelmed
with the odor I mean was just an
incredibly noxious place to live in
terms of the the smell but it had you
know one catastrophic effect which was
basically that the the waste of the
inhabitants living in the city got
crossed with drinking water
in a number of different ways because I
did not understand fundamentally that it
was a good idea to separate your waste
from your drinking water and what ended
up happening is that there arose this
theory which had a long kind of pedigree
called a miasma theory which basically
was holding that every major disease out
there that was kind of arising in
epidemic form most notably cholera was
caused effectively by foul air Edwin
Chadwick the kind of public health
pioneer of the period testified before
Parliament this kind of classic line
saying all smell is disease right
anything you smell that's trying to kill
you basically was the idea and so the
city had instituted this incredible set
of reforms
the beginning in a sense of the public
health movement and a lot of the things
that we take for granted about the state
intervening and the kind of quality of
life and the Sanitation of a city all
these movements were initially formed to
deal with the smell problem but as it
turned out the smell wasn't actually
killing anyone what was killing people
most notably in the case of cholera was
in fact the drinking water contaminated
with this this cholera bacteria that was
coming out of people's excrement and so
the first wave of reforms there was this
incredible reform in 1848 in 1949 called
the public health nuisances Act and what
it basically did in the name of miasma
was decree that everyone had to empty
out the cesspools in their basement and
flush all that stuff into the river and
then they would drink the water from the
river right so you get the idea if you
were a modern-day bioterrorist you could
not come up with a better scheme to
poison the water supply of an entire
metropolitan area and so the cholera got
worse and worse and worse and and
effectively you know at that point the
the almost the entire medical
establishment was basically facing the
wrong way on this issue so the question
that I thought I really wanted to
wrestle with in this book and this is
this is really where the long zoom comes
into focus is to really two questions
one is how does a bad idea stay around
for so long and then when that idea
finally gets to overturn by a good idea
a better idea a correct idea why does
that happen at that point what is it
about the particular kind of
configuration of that moment that that
causes the bad idea to finally die off
when you look at it with hindsight it
should have died off years and years
before but it took so long and then what
was it kind of the threshold point that
that caused it to turn and that kind of
question why do ideas prosper at a
certain point why do some bad ideas
prosper or longer than they should
is it is a question I think that you you
have to to ask an answer from the
perspective of a long zoom
and that and the threshold point really
ended up revolving around this this week
in late August in 1854 at 30 Broad
Street in Soho the densest neighborhood
in all of London a kind of an island of
working-class poverty in the middle of
one of the more kind of posh
neighborhoods Mayfair is just over here
to the left and now on on August 28th of
1854 a very popular well some of you I
know know this story I won't go into it
in too much detail but a very popular
well got contaminated with the bacteria
that causes cholera within the space of
about two or three days the the kind of
most kind of torrential outbreak of
cholera ever to hit London erupted in
that neighborhood within the space of
about 10 or 12 days the neighborhood had
literally been decimated 10% of the
population had died and and probably 50%
would have died if so many people hadn't
fled it was just utter devastation
incredibly you know just gripping tragic
scenes of you know entire families dying
together in there you know one room
flats over the space of 24 hours and
that's kind of agonizing death alone in
the dark just a just a horrible horrible
kind of scene but a very dark moment
turns out to have in a bizarre way this
kind of happy ending because this
outbreak ended up being the turning
point in solving them the riddle of
where the caller was coming from and it
produced ultimately a very famous map
where I got the the title for the ghost
map maybe you have seen bunch of you
probably have seen it in tuff T's books
those of you information architects out
there it's become a kind of an icon of
great classic early cartography and
information design and it was created by
John snow and snow was it just a classic
great 19th century mine lived crucially
lived in the neighborhood just just kind
of down here
on the edge of where the outbreak took
place and what's that saying about snow
is when this story is told about
cracking the code of cholera and the use
of this map and snows Snow's role in it
it's often told in fact in the in the
first version that the Tufte told in his
first book he got all pretty much all
the facts exactly wrong I'm pretty
amazing and I know it's first I know
it's never been corrected he then kind
of retold the story in the next book and
got the facts right but you would think
he would go back and just mentioned that
he had it wrong but basically the story
is often told is this kind of triumph of
information design that snow made this
map of the outbreak and the outbreak and
the map kind of pointed him to the
culprit of this pump and in part that's
true and in part that's it's
fundamentally wrong and and I want to
explain why it's wrong but just to
explain the map for those of you don't
get it the the map basically is is it is
showing deaths at all the various
addresses so these big black bars you
see right around the pump in the center
those are places where the longest one
is a residence where about 20 people
died so it's a bar for each death and
you can basically see the kind of death
radiating out from that pump it gets
spin or the further you get from the
pump and one of the things also that
Tufte didn't mention is a later version
has this grey line going around which is
actually kind of a map of time projected
onto space that that outline is the map
of the area where it was closer to walk
to the Broad Street pump in terms of the
actual kind of time walking down these
crooked London streets than it was to
walk to any other pump so snow had kind
of calculated all the distances and
figured out you know this is the area
where people were likely to use this
pump as opposed to these other pumps and
in fact the disease is the the outbreak
is really contained almost exactly
within the kind of erratic contours of
that line so it is undoubtedly a very
very powerful map and it's it's a great
example of kind of the power of
visualization this could have been a
statistical table of you know distances
from the pump number of deaths that
would have you know
taking you you know three hours to go
through the data to make sense of it
here you you look at that and you say
okay there's something wrong with that
pump so it was very powerful but snow
actually had the idea five years before
he made this map he had come up with the
idea that cholera was in fact in the
water and not in the air in 1848 18-49
he published extensively about it
actually been roundly ignored by the
authorities had done a number of studies
trying to find a kind of comparable
statistical breakdown where he could
show the the likelihood of the of the
cholera being in the water and number of
them are quite convincing but somehow
they never took hold and so he was
effectively kind of sitting around
waiting for something to come along that
would help him make his case and so when
he heard that all these people were
dying just a few blocks from him he went
straight into the belly of the beast and
started knocking on the doors to try and
figure out where people were getting
their water so this interesting kind of
symbiotic relationship that snow had to
the bacteria they needed the bacteria to
kind of destroy a neighborhood in order
that he could save it in a sense but he
also needed help so he came into it with
a theory and he ended up having a
wonderful kind of partner in this
investigation who's always been ignored
in the telling of this story who's the
the Reverend Henry Whitehead who was at
the time about 26 years old this is him
at the end of his life I have no idea
whether he had a beard like that at that
early age and he was just as classic
white hat was this classic you know
local vicar who was hanging out in the
neighborhood knew everyone was just a
classic kind of connector he would you
know was constantly staying in the pubs
until late at night with his
parishioners he was that kind of Vicar
and going over for tea and all that kind
of stuff and and at a certain point in
the middle the outbreak he heard word
that that snow and this local doctor
developed this theory that the pump was
was the cause of the outbreak and he
started investigating because he knew
firsthand that the pump at Broad Street
had the best water in all of Soho and so
he got involved in this case to tracking
down trying to disprove snows theory and
and what he had that snow didn't have
because snow was not really kind of a
social person at all he was bringing
mine but he was not he was not the kind
of person well
Vicker like figure that the white head
was so white head was able to get into
people's houses and talk to them and
interview them at length and to track
down the people who had fled through his
kind of extended social network and he
ended up doing a lot more of the actual
kind of street-level detective work than
snow did and so ultimately actually
drawing upon also a lot of kind of
public information that was being made
freely available by William Farr it was
kind of the head statistician Snow White
had put together this overall kind of
table and a few other kind of charts and
eventually over time convincingly
persuaded the authorities that in fact
the collar was in the water it took
longer than people think but by the time
cholera came back to London in 1866 with
real severity the authorities
immediately treated it as a problem with
the water I they had already started
building the sewer system to deal with
separating out the waste from from the
drinking water and they instructed
everyone around this new epidemic in
1866 to boil their water and that was
the last time that cholera attacked the
city of London so they went from total
ignorance to complete conquering of this
disease in London in 12 years and it was
because of this this confluence of
forces so so how did this happen what
were the different kind of levels kind
of coming together why was the
breakthrough here part of it was because
snow himself was thinking across scales
he was thinking in this kind of long
zoom perspective so he was actively
trying to find the he believed that
there was some kind of microscopic life
that was that was causing this disease
he didn't have the technology of the day
to to actually see it he was constantly
analyzing the water for it but the
microscopes wouldn't let him see it
right about that time somebody in Italy
actually was discovering the cholera
bacteria but snow never heard about it
the scientific world really never heard
about it for many years so he was never
able to see this creature but he was
thinking that it was there and he was
actively looking for it so he was
thinking on the level of microbes but he
was trained as a physician this is
crucial this story and one of the things
that drove him initially to the theory
that it was in the water not in the air
was that the symptoms of the disease the
bodily symptoms of the disease
look like something that you had
ingested rather than something that you
had inhaled so his physical training and
kind of reading the symptoms of the
organs of these you know people who had
died from the disease that was
absolutely crucial to his development of
the theory and then you had that kind of
human scale of whitehead himself both
really the scale of of snow his
particular genius his ability to do
these things his particular background
that led him there and then the kind of
human interpersonal skills that white
had brought to it his ability to kind of
track down all these people to build
that broader social network and then the
ability to look on the scale of the of
the neighborhood itself to zoom out to
the perspective so that you could see
all those deaths arrayed on that map
then the public ability the public
accessibility of all that data that that
far was distributing in a sense part of
the platform for this was an open source
model of government data about mortality
you know the government could have said
okay we're gonna compile all these
statistics about who's dying of what
where but fara had this great idea that
they should make that available to
everyone because someone maybe was going
to find something of interest and
without that open access to the
government statistics the the case
wouldn't have been made convincingly
enough and then snow was also thinking
on the scale of entire cities he did a
massive map of of all the different kind
of water supply companies in in London
and their different cholera rates
depending on where they were getting
their water and the very nature of the
city itself caused this solution in a
sense to come into place by being so
densely populated by making that pattern
visible in the streets and the deaths on
that map the the solution became visible
in a certain way so aunt when when the
question is asked you know how did this
how did snow come to this breakthrough
how do we solve this riddle you can't
answer it convincingly unless you look
at all those different levels right
this is the this is the only kind of
optimal view that that accounts for what
really happened on some level
now this there's another word for this
which is concealed Ian's an old word
repopulate as but yo Wilson a number of
years ago in a controversial book and
one of the things that's that's
controversial about it on some level is
is the encroachment into culture I think
most of us in the room agree that
science works this way in thinking
across different scales at each scale
there's a kind of a discipline
appropriate to that and one of the ways
that science works powerfully is by
connecting the scales up and down the
chain so that one scale makes
predictions about behavior that might
happen on the next scale and then you
bring in an expert on that scale to
verify your your prediction snows idea
was I believe there's something in the
water I can't see it but my prediction
would be that it would have this effect
on a body if ingested and look I've got
this evidence here that shows that and
my prediction would be when you get
those bodies together in a neighborhood
around an infected dominated pump you'll
see this distribution and in each level
he made a prediction that was proved out
by the by the subsequent data that's we
agree that's how science works and
that's the kind of Concilium movement
from from the very small to the very
very large at each step another
discipline where the controversy comes
in is when you connect those kind of
scientific disciplines to the cultural
disciplines of the disciplines of
humanities and a lot of people I think
wrongly believe that that Wilson's
argument is ultimately trying to reduce
everything down to explanations that
come from the sciences when in fact I
think that's not how it actually works
and in fact each level in the chain has
its own autonomy the beauty of the model
is that you can connect them all so the
question is really can you have cultural
concerns right can you bring the realm
of culture and ideas and personal
experience into this into this long zoom
perspective that's that's what I want to
focus on for in a sense the second half
one example of that kind of cultural
reading is is this question of why
miasma stayed around so long as a theory
that's a kind of history of ideas
question why was it there why god why do
people get stuck with it and I think
that again it's one of these cases where
you you need to think about that that
cultural condition across these scales
so it was a very old idea
Purdy's had written about you know the
importance of air in all sorts of
diseases miasma you know is a term that
that he used in some fashion and then
you you also of course have the waves
that that cities were developed
themselves the kind of the lack of
public health infrastructure the lack of
the ability to kind of see these
patterns up until this point both cause
the problem and they caused so much
smell that it was very hard to kind of
override that that immediate kind of
sensory impact which I'll get to in a
sense in in the neuroscience of that
then you had limitations that technology
you just it was very hard to see this
this bacterium so the technological kind
of path was just not quite there yet to
to see around miasma then you had the
kind of contemporary political landscape
but one of the things that happened is
cholera was was more rampant in poorer
more destitute neighborhoods in London
because people were crowded in together
and they were living in worse conditions
and so there was a great kind of
political orthodoxy of the day that said
well these people because of their
morally debauched lifestyles have
somehow brought this disease onto
themselves and that kind of kept it in
in place on some level and then you have
the kind of great man theory of history
where someone like Chadwick who's very
influential in crips testifies in front
of parliament that all smells disease
and people listen to him on some level
that has an impact as well and then the
other thing that I would add to this is
there's a much longer and and smaller
element to this as well which is the
evolution of the human sensory system so
for various reasons we evolved to be
able to detect very small molecules
odors that signal decay where as we do
not have the ability to visually see
bacteria you can you can have a glass of
water that's contaminated with you know
hundreds and thousands of bacteria
cholera bacteria and you won't see any
coloration in the water discoloration in
the water but you can smell you know a
cesspool full of human waste from you
know fifty feet away and what we also
now know for modern brain imaging is
that the smell system actually evolved
into a kind of alarm system in the brain
so that when we smell these odors we
have an immediate kind of revulsion
reaction to them which we do not have to
a glass of water that contains an
odorless bacteria it
and so on some level people when they
would smell these things they would
smell them and think this has to be
killing him on some level this is just
how I spell this in my brain sends off
this kind of alarm system it was I'm
some level just hard to override that
system that evolved in an environment
where people were not around decay and
vast piles of human waste as much as
they were in modern cities so miasma is
this kind of perfect storm of all these
things coming together working on all
these different scales so now let me
let's go from 19th century urban decay
to Sim City one of the things that was
interesting about the the response to to
everything that is good for you as a
defense of popular culture and defense
of the kind of growing complexity of
popular culture is that everyone focused
in a sense on the first half of the book
which was making the argument that pop
culture had gotten more complex and the
you know there was a very interesting
debate about that and what that meant
and what effect it was having but I
always felt that that was kind of the
easy part and that you could make that
case pretty easily and the more
interesting thing was to explain why it
was happening because we had this kind
of long-standing assumption that we
lived in a race to the bottom culture
where everything was getting cruder and
simpler and you know there was a dumbing
down effect everywhere as kind of a
natural law of modern media and society
and in fact what you find is this trend
towards increased complexity that that
was interesting and we should have a
theory of why that is happening and it's
so in the second half of the book I
tried to kind of develop that theory and
what that is is really a long zoom
theory but to just explain a little bit
about the trend you know the original
story that the original kind of
experience that got me on this was was
playing this is a heavy will right theme
to this talk I guess fitting seven or
eight years ago I was on a family
vacation with my wife and I was she had
a seven-year-old nephew she still has a
nephew but he's older now whose name was
Wyatt and it was a rainy day on this
vacation and I had been playing SimCity
a little bit and so I thought oh this
would be fun I'll load up SimCity and
show it to Wyatt and this will be nice
and so we load it up and I gave him what
looking back on it I think was probably
a pretty condescending tour
of the game which is basically a tour of
the graphics you know so it was like go
oh look Wyatt there's that's the mayor's
house that's where I live and look at
the little playground you see the kids
they're playing that's neat and look at
that big tall building and so this goes
on for a while and then at a certain
point I say to him you know you know
look at this area here I've got all
these factories that are all run down
and I can't seem to get this part of
town to work I mean this one's totally
abandoned I'm just stuck here and he
looks at the screen he looks you know
back at me and looks at the screen again
and he's like I think you need to lower
your industrial tax rates you know you
know it's one of those moments for
you're like oh the world just tilted a
little bit you know if I watch and it
was one of those things where I thought
hey you know here is this kid who's
seven he was basically picking this up
it wasn't like ya didn't actually played
the game before but he was just kind of
looking at the graphics in the interface
and just soaking it all in and he was
basically learning you know urban
planning you know principles of
development and lower taxation he'll get
more but you know and he was picking
this all up and if you'd sat him down in
an urban planning classroom you know and
tried to teach him this stuff right he
would it be asleep or out the door and
like three seconds he's seven years old
right but something about this screen
and the game and the whole experience
was he was learning without even
realizing he was learning he was picking
up you know a lot of information and so
I started to think well this is you know
every time I looked around people were
talking about all these video games the
kids are zoning out and everything's so
stupid and I thought you know there's
some something really interesting is
happening that nobody is talking about
here and and you could look at it I mean
you just see in the interfaces them you
go like you think about the progress
from this you know to like to like this
like this is world of warcraft right you
know I mean you can't I love you think
about the interface complexity of these
things now like what this screen from
World of Warcraft like you can't even
see the game right because the interface
is like oh you know like the game is the
interface right I mean the somewhere
back there there's like a dragon or
something like that but but you know
there's this an immense data overload
and this is you know this is legible to
probably many people in this room it's
not actually legible to me but you know
you just look at all the variables going
on here and somebody sits down in front
of this and it's like right okay yeah I
see what's going on
so to be able to you know we went from
you know Oh so once I eat the pellets
they turned blue and I can chase them I
get it I get how this works you know I
can figure this out too you know I can't
even keep up with this this is so that's
the trend and and what part of this is
our ability to kind of adapt at an
ever-accelerating rate to new interfaces
and equal and you know kind of
increasingly complex interfaces which is
big part of it and the thing I've been
thinking about for a long time but but
there's even more to that and it doesn't
just you know it's not just the games
you know I mean I think you know a show
like lost which came out actually after
everything bad was finished you know
it's kind of the great you know to me
kind of vindication of the theory of
this huge mega international hit show
that is just astonishingly complex in
terms of the number you think about
those of you watch it you think about
the number of kind of open variables and
narrative plot lines and mysteries you
know there are literally hundreds and
hundreds of things that we don't know I
mean to the point of great annoyance but
you're still you know they're demanding
an amazing amount of just a buffer a
huge buffer in the in in the kind of
narrative memory of the audience and
with lost it's great because there's a
control study for this - because it's
like people stranded on a desert island
trying to deal with this crazy island
and like you know television we did that
once before right so yes you can look
you so there's Gilligan and there's
Locke and you know you can tell which
one it's got more complex and and in
fact lost is is itself a kind of a long
zoom show so if you think about what
what kinds of plot lines are you know
what are the things that are relevant to
the plot of lost that you know they
really there are there things up and
down the chain that are central to the
plot of the show so there's a basic kind
of ontological question of like are
these people even alive right I mean
that is the thing that the show is
wrestling with all the time like how did
they die and this is all just a dream or
is one of them is Hurley insane and it's
all his hallucination these are the
kinds of questions that the fans are
dealing with and this is huge biological
question of these women I'm not going to
give anything away I promise but
discussion about women on the island
getting pregnant and they're what's
going on and there's this whole there
was an ultrasound
a couple of weeks ago then there's this
kind of sociological thing of the others
and these different groups and and you
know there's this whole question of kind
of large group behavior and who these
people are and bands coming together and
then there's an immense amount of
technology and at old technology new
technology and a basic question of
whether whether there's magic in the
world it's a big question big question
they that people want to know and
there's a lot of technology and the
question is can the seemingly
supernatural things be explained then
you have this shadowy corporate world
the Dharma Initiative kind of hovering
over the whole thing so you have this
kind of global corporate kind of
backstory and then you have the physical
geography of the island so this is not
you know to ask of a show like lost what
is you know front and center in the
narrative where does the narrative live
like it really truly lives on all those
different levels and if you went back to
you know the most complex shows from
from the 80s you want active hill street
blues or something like that you know it
would it would basically live you know
kind of in sociology you know somewhere
between biology and sociology it's like
individual people maybe a little bit of
kind of the city a little bit of the
city and in that but basically live you
know that would you would never have
kind of ontological issues and you're a
big geographic issues and it's basically
kind of clustered in this kind of zone
of people groups of people the work
place crimes the wire by the way is a
show that structured like this too
without maybe the ontology but
everything else is there so so so that's
basically the you know a couple examples
of this increasing complexity so the
question is why is it happening right
why are we having this upward trend and
and so I I kind of tried to identify a
couple of different things
the and and they came from again from
different disciplines and again it's
this kind of convergence of different
scales that that caused this to happen
the first thing that I came across when
I was writing my book about the brain
mind wide open it's something that the
brain scientists yok panksepp calls the
seeking circuitry of the brain which is
a kind of a subsystem in the brain that
is largely kind of modified by the
neurotransmitter dopamine which is
central to many many things but
including addiction and the seeking
circuitry is basically optimized for
systems involving or experiences
involving reward and
right so so anytime you're in a
situation where you basically are
seeking reward you and you have a kind
of a reward craving feeling you have a
very strong drive to explore your
environment if you've ever kind of been
around somebody who's going to like
withdrawal from from a dopamine modified
drug like you know kind of cocaine or
something like that you know the kind of
craving searching your room looking for
the drugged hallucinating all that kind
of stuff is totally the seeking
circuitry going into overdrive
most of us have it in kind of normal
patterns where we you know when we're
hungry we go out and explore for food we
can understand you know how this evolved
it's not that hard to explain but here's
the interesting thing about it if you
accept this idea which i think most
people do that there is this kind of
reward exploration kind of Nexus in the
brain and that it's and it has very
powerful urges and it has very powerful
controls over attention so when we're in
that mode we really are focused and
we're willing to kind of focus on that
at all costs the prediction from this
level from the level of the of the brain
science is that a media form that comes
along structured around reward and
exploration is going to be very
addictive and when I when I first came
across that I was like oh that's what it
is with games that's the structure of
almost all games they're organized
formally around rewards I mean games are
that is one of the basic things that
you're trying to get that prize you're
trying to get that fancy mayor's house
you're trying to get that giant gun
you're trying to get that magic pill
that's in the corner whatever it is
there's rewards and and and almost all
games involve some kind of exploration
some of them you know their whole
multiple genres that are really about
exploration where you're really moving
around the world looking for things and
so that was part of the explanation
there and people spend a lot of time
thinking about like how do we talk about
games what what should be the kind of
critical vocabulary and I always felt
that intuitively talking about them as
narrative form seemed wrong you don't
when you sit down in front of a game
you're not trying to finish the story
you don't really care about the
characters you're not like I wonder how
this is gonna turn out with Zelda you
know yeah you're there because you're
like where is that luck I have to find
that luck I have to you know I've got a
key I need to find the lock right and so
on some level there's that that that
basic sense that were being driven into
these games by this by this kind of
structure
and that's one of the reasons why a
ten-year-old is willing to put up with
this immense complexity is because the
structure of it is really optimized for
the for the structure of his or her
brain and that sense the other thing I
picked up from the from the wonderful
game scholar and education theory
scholar James Paul key is this principle
from cognitive science and kind of
learning theory which is the the regime
of confidence and the idea behind this
is that the space where we learn the
best and where we get into learning in
kind of a flow state where we don't even
realize we're learning is that space
where we're challenged but not too much
right so if it's too easy it's boring it
was too hard it's boring but if it's
kind of like mmm I don't know the answer
to this but I five try I think I can
solve it that's the zone where people
really end up learning without you know
they get kind of pulled in and sucked in
and so one of the things that that's
become clear to a bunch of us who looked
at that is that things like games live
permanently in that state unlike say
novels which have no idea what your
reading skills are and have no idea
whether you're bored or not or whether
you're focused or if you've read the
other literary references that they're
alluding to a game is very much aware of
your skill I mean even the even pac-man
got harder as you got better right it's
built into the kind of DNA of the game
form and so games sit there at that zone
they're always saying ok you're not
quite good enough to go to this next
level when you train your skills you
hone your skills a little bit more then
I'll take you up to that next level and
so people live in this regime of
confidence competence the whole time and
that's another reason why they're pulled
in and that's another reason why they
can be trained to do such astoundingly
overwhelming things like make sense of
that word or craft screen and so then I
started to think well well that's what's
happening even outside the game in the
culture at large that people who grow up
playing video games and grow up learning
these evermore complex interfaces and
grow up playing Zelda at 8 when you sit
them down in front of TV shows if you
put those people down in front of you
know Three's Company they're like I
don't you know this is so easy I want
something you know in the regime of
competence and so a show like lost is
one of the shows and they're a bunch of
other ones that are out to realize that
there's a certain generation that
expects to be challenged and in fact a
show like lost is kind of structuring
itself like a game so it's kind of
played by people it's designed to be
explored it looks a lot like me
in fact in a lot of way it's the kind of
one of the most influential games from
the 90s and one of my favorite examples
of this is this is something I found on
one of the lost fan sites extra-thick
after the second this this thing is
insane after they've just not to give
anything away again but after this end
of season one beginning of season two
there's a mysterious hatch and they blow
up the hatch and they go down and the
first episode of that season is kind of
half of it takes place inside this kind
of underground lair and you know two
days after the show episode episode
aired on one of these fan sites this
image showed up on the fan site and it
is an annotated map of the underground
lair that some insane fan with too much
time on his hands or her hands somehow I
feel like it's his hands did have this
thing and and it's annotated so all
those I don't have you can see his hell
but all those little little dots or have
numbers on them and so you know with
this this is a annotated list and these
are all the screen grabs that they got
so they sat there with the DVR the TiVo
grabbing the frames and then figuring
out the camera positions and the little
maps next to them show where the camera
is and then there's a description of all
this kind of stuff and it was just like
I mean and it goes on I mean it
literally goes on this is you know you
know just the beginning and this is I
don't know it would be equivalent of
like 40 of these pages and you know I'll
be taught you know Kevin always talks
about that wonderful idea that gift
economy I mean it's like I love this
somebody does is they just upload it and
there you go here you go guys I did a
map yeah knock yourself out and you know
within like you know 20 minutes
somebody's like hey great thanks I
noticed one little thing if you could
just you know so-so but this is you know
this is like a game walkthrough right
this is somebody exploring the world of
lost and trying to make sense of it so
this is incredible engagement of people
being pulled into this world and I think
it's because of that exploration drive
the seeking circuitry drive and this
regime of confidence that they've been
trained to the point where they accept
this level of complexity and they expect
this level of engagement and the other
principle which is which is real
a principle that comes out of cognitive
science and neuroscience it comes out of
really more economics and technology is
that is the market that these things are
being kind of thrown into right so there
was a just incredible speech from a
number of years ago that from the 70s
that television executive gave where he
was talking about their basic mission
and they're like look they're only three
channels so we got 30% right out of the
gate right there you know and so all you
know but if we put something on that's
in any way objectionable people are
gonna turn the dial so you get a little
confusing people turn the dial to the
other network if you got if you get a
little too racy different people turn
the dial if you say something a little
politically charged people turn the dial
so what our goal here at I can't
remember if he was ABC or CBS remembers
but he was like our goal here is to make
the least objectionable programming in
the world you know that's what that's
that's how we'll make our money you know
and effectively that was the model when
everything basically aired once and
everything was live from the consumer
point of view right so you you know yeah
there were repeats in the summer but
that you know there was there was barely
anything like syndication you know this
is the 70s it wasn't really cable there
were no DVDs VCRs were just coming to
market and so basically everything you
watch television was a totally live
medium in terms of you in the living
room and it was you know obviously it
was taped or live depending on what was
going on in the other hand but you just
sat there and watched it if you miss
something it was gone
you know people weren't like Oh Starsky
said that to hutch I'm gonna rewind and
see exactly what he said you know I'm
not sure I think I missed something or
was there something in the back of the
screen nobody was thinking that way
about television because the technology
literally kept you from doing it and so
the television got really really simple
for an understandable reason and had it
kind of poorly trained audience who had
no way to pause rewind or watch again
but now you think about the the
condition we live in now you think about
that person with the map who built this
whole thing out of being able to freeze
and look at look at these images and you
think about the after markets for DVDs
you think about buying shows on iTunes
you think about the incredible vast
fortunes made by syndicating things you
know the money is more and more in
making shows that people will want to
watch
multiple times right so there's the
whole economics of television that
started to change at least in in this
world of kind of narrative in fiction
television so there's this huge you know
interest now of like I want to make
something that somebody's gonna watch
and then watch on syndication and then
buy the DVD set and you do that by
making complicated things you do that by
making things where it's interesting to
go back and watch it over again so you
go from least objectionable to most
objectionable I mean most people most
repeatable when you get to most
repeatable most objectionable we still
have you know a fear factor but but for
most repeatable you you know you you're
in this model where you want to watch it
again and again because there's a lot
there there's every time you see it
you'll see something new that Sopranos
24 The Wire these are all shows that are
big hits particularly Sopranos
particularly lost particularly 24 but
that are you know far more complex than
anything that was on television before
so in trying to understand why this
upward trend and complexity happened you
can go all the way from the the kind of
the brain science the kind of cognitive
science the understanding how interfaces
evolve just a pure technological change
of the processing power that's involved
in making these games is obviously
driving a lot of this the new forms of
distribution and then the new kind of
repetition economies to drive all that
to explain why this trend is happening I
called it in the book the sleeper curve
you have to look at all those different
scales the question isn't kind of fully
answered without without thinking that
way I just want to show you one one
other thing that it's not my work then
I'm sure a lot of you don't know about
but it's an example again from the kind
of cultural side it's it's a Franco
Moretti's book maps grass and trees
which came out a year or two ago and I
think it's actually one of the most
important books of kind of cultural
criticism that's come out in in a long
time and what Moretti is trying to do
he's at Stanford and was my old mentor
in my grad school days so there's some
overlap and in our work we're Eddie's
trying to take in a sense this he's not
called it a long zoom perspective but
he's going to moving back and forth
between the different scales of reading
and the basically literature has been
kind of anchored in either the kind of
close reading of looking at the text or
them connecting the
texts maybe to the kind of cultural
moment and seeing how the text kind of
represents that moment in some ways what
what Moretti's trying to do is kind of
greatly expand the the approach so he's
made all these you did a book called the
atlas of the European novel that looked
at how these novels actually move
through space which is really
interesting a whole Geographic
perspective on plot lines that that open
up a whole new avenue but this last one
he got tours through a bunch of
different ways you've kind of levels of
zoom that you can look at any sudden
these it's great of these really crazy
charts like this is a history of good of
novelistic genres from 1740 to 1915 and
it's all these I don't have the titles
on there because you would be able to
read them because there's so many but
it's like you know the the kind of
Newgate Prison novels and the silver
fork novels and the nautical bubbles and
the the building's ramón and all these
different genres that proliferated and
so basically they catalogued the actual
stuff he didn't look at the Canon and he
didn't look at kind of the ante Canon
you looked at the whole system of
production to try and fight what was the
in the entire ecosystem of literature
that people were reading and what was
happening to the kind of the species in
that ecosystem and when you when you
when you zoom out to that perspective
you find out a bunch of things one there
are a lot of species we didn't know
about right i mean the diversity of the
system is pretty interesting and too
they keep dying off at this incredible
rate so there's this very kind of strong
thing we're like you know 10 or so kind
of appear as a kind of hegemony for
awhile and they die off after about 25
years and then another 10 kind of comes
into place and there's a little
variation there but it's but there's way
more diversity than then one would have
thought and there's way more turnover
they have these shorter lifespans and in
franca yes this Kate turn for this kind
of approach which is distant reading
instead of close reading it's just in
reading what happens when you zoom out
far enough to look at the at the whole
system but then he also goes in all the
way to look at devices kind of the
evolution of literary devices inside
novels so he's he's looking at actual
kind of formal properties as they get
picked up and become standardized so one
of my favorite examples of this is the
evolution of the detective story kind of
perfected by Conan Doyle
but before Conan Doyle kind of reached
this perfection there was a long period
of kind of experimentation
where there are lots of different
approaches to telling a detective story
and many of them very comic and if any
of them not very entertaining and it's
basically because people hadn't quite
figured out the rules yet that we're
kind of satisfying to a reader and and
it basically revolves around clues right
what the standard that eventually got
kind of hit upon at kind of at the end
of Sherlock Holmes and there are a
couple of Sherlock Holmes stories where
this is not true but but Conan Doyle
kind of formalizes is the idea that the
detective story has to have decodable
Clues so the clues are actually visible
to the reader in some fashion they're
going to mention that they show up and
there can there's some form of their
connection to to the to the eventual
kind of resolution the mystery has to be
has to be visible in some way so there's
a whole range of detective stories where
there were no clues at all that were
published where people were like yeah
this guy was murdered and what are we
gonna do we don't know oh my god it was
her you know you know it was just like
who was exciting somebody was murdered
and then they found out who it was and
there was none of that sense of like oh
I thought it might have been that
because you mentioned that there was
that and it was kind of doyle finally
kind of figured that out and then ever
since then you know that's been the
standard and that's the way you tell
detective stories and if and if somehow
you come along and you forget to mention
the key thing that was staring you right
in the face people say that's not a very
satisfying you didn't play by the rules
on some level so in this context like
Frank is going back and looking at the
actual kind of evolution of the form on
the level of the device so what I think
it's starting to get built here is the
beginning of a kind of a long zoom
theory for for how literary systems work
and I think the big question here I mean
you have you know the broad movement of
societies you have literary markets
people increasingly focusing on they're
kind of the flow of books and what
people were buying you have the existing
biographical history of authors which
we've been doing forever in terms of
literary study we have kind of neurology
and now we're getting better and better
at thinking about the circulation and
evolution of devices but I think there's
one last link there which is the logical
link down to the individual mind what's
going on in the mind reader's so in this
particular case if you believe that
there is in a kind of evolutionary sense
this selection pressure on certain
devices
that there's a lot of experimentation
and then the marketplace kind of decides
that they like their clues decodable
right then one of the things we have to
explain is what is that process whereby
a brain is able to on one level have a
position on a literary device without
probably being conscious of the device
itself right there aren't people saying
like that Conan Doyle was good he has
decodable clues there's just this kind
of sense of like that was satisfying I
like that one better than the others
right I think most kind of theories of
literary devices will have will have to
assume that the audience is not
conscious of that and yet somehow they
are conscious of that and if you get
into that realm and if your language
gets murky like saying somehow they are
consciously aware of it that's when you
have to be more specific and that's when
you have to be able to say okay you know
let's let's figure out how this actually
works
we actually have models for this I mean
I've got a three year old son who's
learning how to talk and he's going
through that phase where he's he's
learned how to you know conjugate
regular verbs and so he's making all
those mistakes by taking a regular verbs
that he's and making all these you know
he's saying things like I bring did
because somehow he has learned the rule
that that's how you you you make a past
tense verb and he's executing that rule
very nicely it's producing the wrong
word so he noticed it but she obviously
he's not conscious of that he's not
aware that this is actually how you you
know this is how you conjugate these
things so there may be some kind of
neuroscience basis for this that we can
understand we can understand what's
actually going on in the brain but if it
gets to the level I mean it's like that
classic cartoon where they have the
giant science equation on the chalkboard
and it's all these numbers and formulas
and things like that and another part
that goes on here and in the middle it
says that a miracle occurred you know
that's where we are here we get you know
we're really good we're getting better
and better at kind of connecting these
levels and then we get to the actual
brain and it all gets fuzzy and we're
like well we don't talk to those people
but we should be talking to those people
and they should be talking to us there's
a lot to talk about right
so the question is how do you kind of
exercise this you know what is what is
the you know how do if this is an
important way to think and obviously
it's an important way to think about how
ecosystems work it's an important way to
think about political systems work and
cultural systems so if this is something
that that we want to do more and more
how do we kind of exercise this
cognitive muscle more and more and it's
a great question I don't have all the
answers but it's going to be very
interesting to see what happens with for
will rights new game because as far as a
game is the one that has been the kind
of most explicitly designed as a kind of
a long zoom thing I mean it was inspired
by powers powers of tannin and a number
of other things in this mode and most
you know this but I'm sure but it goes
through as a game you know you kind of
start with this a little a little
microscopic creature and then you know
you kind of evolved into this bigger
creature that you get to kind of
intelligently design and then then you
get out there and then you're kind of on
the level of your ecosystem and you're
hunting and seeking and looking for
reward and then you then you actually
get you build a tribe I don't have an
image for that butBut and then you start
building a little civilization in cities
and you kind of get to that scale and
then you start thinking about planets
and intergalactic exploration all kind
of stuff and so it's really it's it's
the great kind of embodiment of this
perspective and you know it's it's a
tool for this kind of thought and Howard
rheingold's cradle traits what I don't
know and you know I asked well about
this one he showed me a demo and I've
never quite figured it out I think the
test will be how much changes on one
scale effect changes on the other scale
because there on some level that I mean
it's going to be an extraordinary thing
and it's gonna be an amazingly fun
experience I'm sure but in terms of
exercising the brain in this kind of
conciliate way which what you want to
have is something where you tinker with
the microscopic life and you see changes
in your city right that's that's the
real kind of mind opening kind of
awe-inspiring thing about this is is
that you're able to actually move back
and forth between the different scales
and see the effects they have
on each other and to see it all as one
kind of integrated whole I think that
that that will be a pretty powerful tool
for the for the mind we'll see I come
back to the Joyce quote after he writes
out a little description of himself in
the world as this great passage where he
says he reads down the list again then
he read the Flyleaf from the bottom to
the top till he came to his own name
that was he
and he read down the page again what was
after the universe nothing but was there
anything after the universe to show
where it stopped before the nothing
place began it was very big to think
about everything and everywhere that's
that's kind of what I want to leave you
with it was very big it is still very
big to think about everything in
everywhere but it's also never been
easier thank you very much
I had to write down those last notes is
it true you're an English major I have a
dropout from grad school so I have to
every now and then I have to bring it
back you know I'm amazing you and Lou
Reed if not far what I thought could
never happen okay a question from Ryan
grant who's where he's back there right
I see Brian that's helpful when you
point at the person raising their hand
um can we move from recognizing zoom
levels to a really useful taxonomy
allowing us to measure which areas are
most in need of conciliation you're
pointing out you know we aren't looking
at neurons the way we should that's
really that's great a great question I
mean the part of it is we know there is
a big fault line there in in precisely
the zone that I've kind of focused on
here but between the you know kind of
hard the heart the software you get in
the science is when you get to the kind
of that level where you start to get
into kind of cultural theory and it's in
some ways you know all my books have
been one of the unifying themes they
have despite their various topics it's
been trying to bridge that gap a little
bit because I've always felt that those
those folks needed to be talking to each
other and so there's a question of like
what kind of work needs to be done and
then there's a question of like what
kind of links need to be established and
it's you know in that dispute it's kind
of everybody's fault on some level I
mean I should correct myself I was a
semiotic major and in English
grab this dude more of me oh yeah yeah
right so so I so I grew up you know my
kind of college years were spent you
know deconstructing things and the idea
that one would you know kind of talk
about you know the truth value that was
coming out of the sciences was something
you know would get you kind of kicked
out of the seminar like when I wrote
emergence which has a whole long thing
about ants in it I saw an old friend of
mine
kind of stayed in that world and she I
said oh I'm writing this book is
partially about ants and
self-organization and she's like oh you
know there's a whole discourse about
ants and the kind of rhetoric of ants it
shows up in a couple of points and
there's a whole kind of semiology of
kind of the ant that shows up and I was
like no actually I'm writing about
actual ants and so you know the one hand
you had a lot of hostility coming from
from the humanities and the other side
you had people just not paying attention
to it and in fact there's a there are
some useful things to do between those
two groups even even in the you know
kind of the the semiotic swirled can
connect very well to to the brain
sciences people would actually talk so
you can see those kind of fracture
points I'm I don't know I mean the
problem you get into is people
specialize and you know this is like
Denise Caruso's I would bring a bigger
project you know is how do you get
people to think outside their discipline
and and if you can start to do that then
I think maybe we might be able to say
okay here are the here are the blind
spots we have right now where there's
like there's an obvious connection that
needs to be made and nobody is making it
but you can't see that until you kind of
peer over the wall so that totally
didn't answer your question but that was
that was my way of dodging it a little
raises a question if you've got
something now to sort of offer back to
these literature departments of a post
semiotic we think about literature and
humanities and such do you have that
well I think you know it's interesting I
was at a conference that the Moretti had
organized about two weeks ago at
Stanford and I talked a little bit about
some of these ideas and one of the
things that that some people were just
like what you know what do you know I
don't want to learn all that and then
some people some people actually got up
and said I have to say they got up and
they said you know when you talk about
the empiricism and the truth value of
science you know that's what led to
colonialism you know so there's
something you know there's that still
that kind of attitude on some level
which I just was like well yes that's
true but it's more complicated in that
right and then but then there are other
people said I'm really interested this
but if I go to the brain science folks
they will not answer my calls you know
they're just not on time for me
what do you want me to study genres you
know like I'm not gonna be literary
devices I want to scan people's brains
while they read Conan Doyle like that's
not how I'm gonna get tenure you know so
it's hard you know it's hard on that
level and I can understand that it's
that it's hard on both ends will they
wire up kids playing games yeah well
they have actually that they've done a
bunch of that and I in my mind open I've
stuck my head in an fMRI which is a
whole other hilarious story but one of
the things that they found they've
looked at dopamine activity in game play
I think separate from from my argument
about the seeking circuitry and they do
in fact find that they're you know in
these parts of the brains that these
parts of the brain that involved the
this kind of reward exploration matrix
there is this kind of dopamine surge it
seems to be happening so it's an
interesting argument in terms of the
addiction question it does show you you
know in some level that there is
something kind of powerful there going
on and that is why when you talk to your
children when they're playing video
games they don't hear you at all right
which leads to the question what are the
best drugs to play video games on now
that I'm the parent of three kids I
can't answer that question we could
probably pull the audience on that okay
here's a question from Kevin Kelly I
love the opening sentence it's only 2007
says we've gone from TV shows with three
levels of scale to ones with seven
levels of scale only in several decades
where will we be in 100 years is there a
limit to how many levels of scale are
fun good desirable and bearable I have a
feeling that number seven didn't come
from nowhere well I you know I feel a
little bit that I'm asking myself that
question when I look at something like
that World of Warcraft interface because
that's the point where I started to
think I'm getting old
like I can't I can't kind of keep up
with that level of complexity I don't
have the kind of the time and maybe I
don't have the kind of chops anymore to
kind of be able to I feel like it's
already reached a point where it's
extending beyond my kind of perceptual
systems and it's only you have to be you
know 10 years younger to be able to get
on no they were older far the workout
players out there so but I'll tell you
you know one of the most interesting
conversations about this and I've ever
had was with Antonio Damasio the
wonderful brain
Justin writer and Antonio we were
talking about this idea of the
acceleration of culture and it's kind of
again this cliche we live in times of
everything's going faster and faster and
how fast can it go
and what DiMaggio was saying is that we
have to understand that that that
effectively the brain in broad strokes
brain works at two different speeds and
the the the kind of frontal lobe you
know raw cognition stuff that all the
stuff that happens here happens really
fast
he's like things that we do there we
seem to be we seem to have a lot of
headroom as to where we can get we can
go faster and faster on it's amazing how
fast people can get but the emotional
system of the brain is a bodily system
and emotional decisions which are
DiMaggio shown are kind of central to
rational behavior in many different ways
they literally they happen on the scale
of like minutes so for you to get that
kind of feeling in your body that this
is the right thing to do which is
central to being a smart intelligent
person that that takes a minute or two
minutes and it's never going to get
faster and so what he's what he's trying
to say is that there are certain types
of decisions or certain types of
activities that in fact we've got a lot
of room we could probably just
accelerate accelerate accelerate but
when things come down to things like
kind of moral decisions we've already in
a sense started to hit the limits and we
won't be able to get around that so in a
sense even inside our own heads we've
got to come we've got a version of that
that chart with the two different scales
of time okay here's a question from
Robin right over here I love the notion
of using the top to bottom the long zoom
analysis to understand and solve thorny
problems speaking of thorny problems can
you do a quick long zoom on Iraq I
really can't I've just no I mean I just
I it's a great someone should do it but
I'm not the person to do it
yeah there I just totally I didn't even
try to answer that question
skipping that one if you got another
thorny problem that long zooming helps
you crack
well I'm what I'm trying to figure out
is if there is a certain the thing I'm
trying to work on in this next book that
that this is all kind of leading towards
although I've been very distracted
recently and I haven't done any work on
it but in terms of this question of you
know where if you go back to the snow
scenario in the collar like where the
question where good ideas come from why
do they and why do some ideas just kind
of shoot out of the gates and others get
stuck and why do bad ideas sometimes get
stuck that idea that you that you need
to think about in a long-term
perspective and so you know when you're
thinking about creating environments
that will be hospitable to good ideas
you know a bit like this stuff that you
were writing about in how buildings
learn you need to think about the kind
of brain chemistry of the people who
you're trying to encourage have a good
ideas you need to think about the
interfaces that are interacting with
those you know kind of brain systems and
then you need to think about the
buildings and the social groups around
those interfaces and those people and
you need to think about the overall
cultural ecosystem of how ideas move and
somehow this is where it gets really
this is my that a miracle occurs right
now I haven't gotten anywhere near
answering this but I think there
probably are certain configurations of
those different levels that are
particularly resonant in some way where
they kind of a line and that's my hunch
and a big part of it in some way is he
this is one of the great mysteries I
think where hunches come from right I
mean when I went when I wrote emergence
I had been sitting there for a long
period of time trying to decide if I was
gonna write a book about brains or about
cities and I was reading all this brain
science books and I was reading all
these books about urban design and then
somebody gave me of this great book of
19th century maps
I'm actually I got two copies of it for
my birthday as kind of a coincidence and
it had this map of Hamburg that's
reproduced in the book and it looks
uncannily like the profile view of the
human brain and I thought oh maybe it's
one book maybe it's a book about brains
and cities it's a book about the common
properties that unites brains and cities
that would be a really cool book I have
no idea what that means right you know
and I have no idea what that means
but I thought about it for six months
and then it's
evolved into into emergence and so the
thing that I think is so interesting is
one what's happening in your brain when
you have a hunch like that you don't
have the idea you have a tiny little
sliver of the idea but something is you
know reverberant in in your head in some
way and then how do you create
environments where hunches like that can
prosper you know how do you create
environment over people who have this
half-baked idea and show up at the
product meeting and say I've got a
really half-baked idea that's entirely
wrong but I think there's something
there how do you create environments
where those things have a have an
afterlife so that six months later when
somebody find it finally figures it out
and completes the puzzle it actually has
a chance to succeed there might be
something here in a mutual colleague and
Brian he you know because he recently
did it do it with him in London I think
yeah yeah and he's been in the program
here a couple times in fact he's
basically a co-author with me of that
pace layering diagram that you were
referring to we crank that out in his
studio one evening and Alexander drew it
visibly when you work with Brian and
London and ghost nappa sort of your
subject what's Brian's perspective on
long zooming well I think you know he's
also he's obviously been so interested
in spores as well and he I think he just
he just kind of gets it and he's the
he's the great example of somebody
coming from the kind of creative arts
who has completely embraced all the
information he can get from other
disciplines you know so he you know he's
been completely immersed in AI meets a
ton of science he reads all this kind of
stuff and he's completely open to and
there's no sense of like no this is my
territory you know what's interesting to
him are kind of problems that kind of
move back and forth between them so he's
fascinated with the technology of idiots
anyway has no kind of sacred sense of
art as being separate from empiricism or
you know technology it's just like well
what can what can you do what can you do
new when you're gonna mix those things
together and in a fresh way and I think
that's you know why is just such a great
mind to be around
one of the distinction distinction she
draws between Sardis and scientists
doesn't think there's that many
distinctions but one of them is that
scientists are willing to explain what
they're doing and artists will conceal
that behind the mystique of the
mysterious artist my favorite my
favorite story about you know it's
vaguely related to this but I just loved
so much it there is a wonderful blogger
and in London ooh a read occasionally
named Matt Webb and one day he put on
his blog he was like I'm gonna test this
six degrees of separation theory I would
like to meet Brian Eno that's one of you
150 people who read my blog must know
someone who knows someone who knows
someone who can get Brian Eno to me so
go at it and so he publishes this and so
I come across this blog and I just
happen to come across as like an hour to
after you put it up and so I sent you
know a note and I was like Brian it
would be really cool if you would just
go to this guy's blog I can you know
post something in the comments section
and so you go back to the blog and
there's like immediately like there four
or five people were like I know somebody
who used to work as a roadie for you two
who maybe could get to them and I know
somebody worked at a gallery where he
had a show and then post number three is
high that was far too easy Steven Steven
Johnson said evil you should have tried
some kind of African goatherd or
something like that it was one degree of
separation but what I love is the next
five posts after that work I know
somebody who might be able to get to him
through here like nobody you know as so
finally I said Matt a note and I was
like dude I deliver Brian Eno in like
two hours what's going on and he was
like oh I didn't think was really Hugh
on the internet nobody goes you brandy
no that's the problem with it all right
sorry off message that's another form of
zooming Carlos looks like malts on
something like that ask what are the
elements of the long zoom that will
finally lead to the long overdue
breakthrough in education yeah well what
am I one of the issues I have right now
with the the the state of education
which I kind of got into I'm not I'm an
amateur on this subject so hear me out
but take some of it with a grain of salt
but but the problem I have right now
with the question of you know what are
the kids learning which I got into a
little bit with everything bad it's good
for you
is that the kinds of skills that I think
are being enhanced by all these
technologies the kind of skills you get
by playing spore or playing SimCity or
playing World of Warcraft the ability to
kind of process large amounts of
information the ability to adapt a new
interface this ability to kind of query
large bodies of information to build
kind of virtual connections with people
to you know kind of explore spaces learn
new kind of social systems and rules
on-the-fly all those skills that I have
to believe are being greatly enhanced by
these experiences and we aren't testing
for any of them right we don't know
anything about how this generation looks
in terms of these skills compared to
generations 20 or 30 years ago it's just
not something that we've kind of
routinely test for but I I ask you I
mean you know if you think about what
you're actually going to use when you're
30 or 40 in your job environment is it
going to be the ability to master new
forms of interface new technology the
ability to search large volumes of
information build virtual connections
with people do all that concept or is it
going to be doing algebra which are the
skills that are going to be the most
important to your day-to-day life and I
think most of us would agree it's it's
the former not the latter and yet we
know everything about you know basic
math skills and we know nothing about
these other skills and so the
the problem on some level is we don't
you know we're not necessarily teaching
these things enough and we have no idea
what the kind of baseline is in terms of
in terms of how these skills are
developing so I I look out there and I
you know you do see the test scores the
test scores are not always as bad as
they look because you have to control
for a bunch of different things we have
an incredible wave of immigration of
people who come into the country with
with lower education levels and many
foreign language speakers and so when
you control for that actually the test
scores actually better than people make
out but nonetheless I mean you look
around at the society I mean I have
twenty five year-olds ever been as
central to the kind of innovation engine
and of the economy as they are today I
mean I just look around and I see so
many people who are out I mean look at
this part of the world who are doing
things like that and so I don't yet see
the kind of brain drain we're falling
behind the rest of the world kind of
problems that we've been hearing about
for twenty or thirty years so you know I
think we probably are doing a slightly
better job than we realize we're doing
that's my that's my raises the question
of what you're describing is it's
happening anyway right and would it be
better or worse it was happening
intentionally well I mean you know part
of it the conversation as we learn to
play a games in school right I mean that
you know there's definitely when you see
something like spore you definitely say
there's this is absolutely be in every
classroom I mean there's why would
anybody ever not kind of sit there and
build a whole universe and all these
different levels I mean you would learn
so much more and kids would you have to
tear them out of the classroom and and I
think that's very there's something very
sympathetic about that right but but you
know I had a great line about it
actually when I was talking to him about
it for The Times Magazine story about
Spore I mean he said that the flip side
of that is which is apparently something
his wife said to him is one of the other
things you have to learn in life is to
kind of tolerate doing very boring
things and so he was like my dream
school would be you know four days of
Spore and one day of mandatory Latin
like that would be you know that mix
would be the total dream school that
probably describes the reality
I'm gonna have finished with two
questions one at a very general level
and one a very specific one seems
appropriate Danny Hillis coming into the
general level says do multiple levels
really exist or is that just our way of
understanding things if they do exist
why do they exist Danny you could you
you can answer that one for me right
[Laughter]
yeah I think well I mean it a little bit
it gets down to the question of what you
believe emergent behavior is right I
mean some of us is the things on some
level come together and they produce
this higher level behavior that seems
fundamentally different from what was
going on one layer down you know I
it does feel intuitively right to me to
say that the you know the emotional
feeling that I have is different from
the actual molecules of the
neurotransmitters in my brain that there
is something fundamentally different
that kind of conceptually happens there
and that there are different rules that
seem to happen at those at those
different scales so once you have you
know kind of different behaviors and
different rules that you see I mean it's
I think you have to be to be very kind
of far removed or thinking at a very
high level to not have those different
disciplines be useful on some level
still but but I'm sure Danny it's ahead
of me on this point so Danny do you have
a follow up question where is dude
there's like I'm just starting okay Jane
McGonigal gets down to cases
where's Jane right here can you talk
about the connection between the long
zoom and your current project called
outside oh great yeah yeah outside in is
actually connected to long zoom
end-to-end to coast map so this is what
I've been doing that's why I haven't
been writing this book cuz I've been
kind of working on this web project kind
of full-time outside in is an attempt to
organize
as much information as possible online
starting with kind of local bloggers but
kind of moving beyond that that's
related to the kind of human scale of
neighborhoods and communities so it's
part of this very interesting movement
that a lot of people been talking about
if they're kind of geospatial web and
something that I've been writing about
in one form or another for almost 10
years now the idea that the connection
between the kind of virtual organization
and connectivity of the web uniting that
with real world places is a very
powerful cocktail and it was something
I'd been kind of dealing with in theory
and then I saw two things kind of
converge one was Google Maps and the
release of kind of open api's that lets
you kind of manipulate that data so you
didn't have to build an entire you know
kind of 30 million dollar geographic
information system on your own and then
the rise of all these local bloggers who
were writing about their communities and
so when I was when I was writing
ghost map I was thinking a lot about the
Henry whiteheads of the world that
people had that kind of local knowledge
and snow as well of their neighborhoods
and then I was reading all these great
bloggers in Brooklyn where I live who
were writing about their communities and
providing a kind of a service that I was
just not getting anywhere else and I
found myself you know the the kind of
first cup of coffee media experience
that I would go to would be you know the
local blog or brownstone or and in
Brooklyn to see what was going on you
know and when when you start having a
new kind of forum being the thing that
you want to read first over that cup of
coffee that's time to pay attention
something somebody interesting is going
on and so we stack up of us got together
and decided what we could do is try and
organize all those local bloggers who
were out there and try and tag all the
information that was coming from them
geographically so not just you know
sometimes it's on the fuzzy category of
a neighborhood sometimes it's a very
specific place that has a specific
latitude longitude or an address but
we're grabbing all that information we
were in like something like 60 cities
3,500 neighborhoods around the country
and you can literally this is the zoom
component of it you can you can type in
your neighborhood or your zip code and
you'll see the whole conversation that's
going on in the blogosphere or other
things that people are saying about that
neighborhood and then you can literally
just drag the map around and you can see
other conversations that are going on or
you can zoom out or zoom in
and kind of widen your focus and see
more and what it turns out is that the
there's Mensa useful stuff that you can
do that way that's not just you know
looking for a Starbucks right so we have
natural kind of scales geographically
that that kind of shift based on our
needs so one of the things you can do is
you can say show me only show me stories
about crime in my zip code alone because
I'm very interested in you know if
somebody gets mugged on my block I want
to know about it but you might zoom out
all the way to find out about you know
to the entire city to find out about you
know poetry readings or something like
that because that's something you're
gonna travel across the city to go see
and so you can do all those things
really intuitively so it's it's it's
pretty interesting and the other thing
that's happened is we kind of imagined
that there was this kind of long tail of
neighborhoods that that kind of
traditional media wasn't organizing
properly that people actually thought
about their communities that was the
kind of zone that people felt the most
passionately about outside their family
and so if we could fill that need that
was really interesting and then along
the way we started building these very
specific pages for individual places
like the local public school or a
restaurant or controversial real estate
development and those pages basically
grabbed every story that's come along
that's relevant to that from the New
York Times from the local bloggers from
something a user is coming so we've
created like fifteen thousand of these
places with each with a dedicated page
and what's happening is these pages are
ranking very highly in Google because
there's not a lot of competition so last
week we started our number one entry
page was for the regional correctional
detention facility in Los Angeles
California where a certain Paris Hilton
is gonna be spending forty five days
right soon and we had a page for it
because there were stories about her
going to this thing and there was
basically you know there was a there's a
page for that jail created by the jail
and then we're number two you know in
terms of the Google rankings for it so
we got all these people coming into that
and so turned out actually that you know
this is part of Chris Anderson lesson
here the tale is even longer than we
thought you know we thought it was
neighborhoods in fact it's like you know
the school the jail and and so there's
that kind of big unexplored kind of
world of local geography that we think
is it's gonna be cool it's it's it up
outside got in I
you want to check it out and very soon
every single one of the neurons and
Stephen Johnson's brain will have its
own website
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]